oh hey come on in have some snacks have
a drink have a seat and let's enjoy some
couch co-op there's no better way of
having long lasting memories with your
friends than to play games cooperatively
while sitting at punching length of each
other when I say campaign co-op I mean
that you're cooperatively working
together not battling each other this
removes a lot of great games like Mario
Kart nidhogg towerfall gang be sports
friends samurai gun these are all great
games but I'm talking about completing
campaigns with a buddy by your side
there's this innate feeling of joy you
get when you work together side by side
to take down a massive boss or
strategically solve a puzzle
or just get weird the element of human
interaction gives us an extra element of
joy when you're sitting with your
friends and utter delight meant or
intense anger and sadly these side by
side gems are getting harder and harder
to find so here's a comprehensive list
of some of the best couch co-op games to
ever grace my living room Castle
Crashers is pure hack and slushy fun
with friends or people can play together
at a time and even though teamwork is
necessary you level up and keep your own
loot you work together to attack bosses
from multiple angles and revive your
fallen teammates to progress there is an
element of selfishness though when the
loop rains down and at the end you get
to battle each other to the death see
who claims the princess so there's a
really good balance between camaraderie
and every man for himself it's also an
incredibly stimulating game visually
there's always something weird happening
so it's constant excitement from
beginning to end
anyone who grew up in an arcade can tell
you classic gauntlet was all about co-op
fun the new version rekindles that
classic love with updated graphics and
remixed audio and a few twists on
gameplay what we all knew of bond
potions are now relics and they work
just as you'd want them to but this
version makes death a bit more of a
problem you can run a little lives in
this one pretty easy so it makes you
really appreciate life as you have it
there are only twelve levels in three
realms so you might burn through this in
an evening or two but it's timeless then
you'll enjoy the exploration and the
combat and yelling at elf for always
needing food whether or not this brings
back a wave of nostalgia gauntlet is a
solid game to take on Resident Evil 5
follows the beloved formula of four but
adds a second player during the missions
you can trade weapons and ammo as you
need which is good because the game
mostly focuses on action this means
uncovering hidden ammo gold and herbs is
a huge bonus when playing with an ally
Resident Evil 5 lends itself incredibly
well to couch co-op as you can
communicate really easily with each
other when one of you needs assistance
with kicking off an infected or there's
the occasional puzzle that requires both
of you working together to leave a
particular area or just take down the
large boss
there's a whole slew of Lego games from
Star Wars to Batman and they're all
pretty good if you were ever a fan of
the Harry Potter books or movies this
game is a perfect addition playing with
a companion really helps convey that you
are going to Hogwarts and learning the
spells you can head to Diagon Alley and
get unique costumes and spells and
chocolate frogs spells of a small
variation depending on who you play so
you get a sense of Independence from
your friend you can finish the story in
a mere six hours but you'll find that
there's a lot of meat in the game
uncovering all the secrets and
collectables allowing for hours of fun
Hogwarts is such a fantastical world
that you'll be really glad you had a
friend there to share the experience
with Super Mario 3d World takes a lot of
what we liked in galaxy and gives you
what you wanted a chance to play it with
a buddy and when I mean buddy I don't
mean that star that just like stands
around and collects coins and has no
actual purpose in this one you're your
own character with your own trademark
news like peaches hover the difficulty
is flexible for most ages you simply
come back bubble style and keep playing
and even in death there's typically
humor in the silly scenario you're in
like riding in this oversized cartoon
dragon you'll actually appreciate having
those extra set of eyes to spot all the
green stars which are really well hidden
throughout the level and those extra
hands come in handy when grabbing as
many coins as you can in a short burst
time playing with friends isn't just a
nice feature in Mario 3d World it's what
makes the game so distinctively
enjoyable
well I can't have a list of amazing
co-op experiences without debatably the
best couch co-op campaign ever debatably
you get to play as one of two amazing
characters the intense sergeant Marcus
Fenix or the level-headed Dom Santiago
as they take on the Locust Horde and cut
into their faces with a rad chainsaw gun
the story is actually deeper than you
might think and there are moments that
you'll be glad to share with friends we
also benefit from your comrade to find
Cod tags which are placed throughout the
area as well as letters and medical
records to help make the world feel real
this is a game you'll really tell your
friends to go the opposite direction to
flank the enemy in the middle and feel
really good about yourself when it's
executed well it can give you this XCOM
feel where you're strategically planning
out moves ahead of time so it's not just
pointing and shooting you're working
together to figure out the best strategy
to take everyone out with minimum damage
puzzles a vast amount of puzzles you and
a friend can work through together
there's something incredibly satisfying
about playing through good puzzle with
friends not only who's gonna figure it
out first and then explain it to the
other person but who's gonna be the
first executed if you're not Laura your
toe tap with completely different skills
that benefit in different ways Laura's a
little bit more agile with toe tap being
kind of more of the muscle and it's a
really nice balance to see how they work
together to solve these different
puzzles it's worth mentioning that there
is another Tomb Raider called temple of
Osiris and it allows for four people but
guardians alight is my personal favorite
because it's a bit longer and it's got
some real head-scratching puzzles
you can pretty much pick one anyone and
start playing from beginning to end the
series is pretty engaging and genuinely
interesting and with the halo Master
Chief collection you can easily
alternate between the stories and choose
the difficulty which is best for you
although you should keep it legendary
the horizontal split screen gives you
more than enough screen space to take
out enemies while seeing all the
necessary gauges although there won't be
much difference between you and your
friends the gun that you select actually
can have a huge impact on the way that
you might go about a particular area you
can work together to flank enemies or
you can just both go in guns blazing
it's actually fine to die in this game
because then you can just find different
ways to attack the same area and you
find it really enjoyable to figure out
what works for you too and what didn't
and you'll always share the bond of the
I'll Drive you shoot moments
it's hard to try and live up to portal
this one-of-a-kind game that really
makes you think that you are so smart
when you solve a puzzle portal 2 gives
it a fantastic effort and does something
that the first game never did it lets
you try these puzzles with a friend you
can play portal 2 online the game gives
you pain buttons to hint at the other
player what to do where to put your
portal but honestly I think this game is
just played better in the same room you
can talk it out between each other and
be really clear about where they should
be and what your plan is
there's also moments where you can be
silly by tripping each other up just to
be jerks portal 2 drives communication
between two people working together to
achieve a common goal and they can do
this without stress or frustration it's
just you two and GLaDOS I went with
Borderlands 2 even though the pre-sequel
is more recent
because Borderlands 2 is my favorite you
play with your buddy as an assassin gun
Zurcher siren or go commando with a
group of characters that each play
completely differently the dialogue is
playful and witty and actually funny but
the story isn't why you play collecting
loot and sharing weapons is way more fun
with someone else
I either play it with someone or I don't
play it at all it's such a good feeling
to take down a massive boss and then go
through the loot to find an amazing
weapon for yourself and sometimes you
find something that's just the best to
give you your friend Borderlands 2 will
make you want to help out your teammate
and make them the best player they can
be because a strong character will be
better to help you out when you need it
and most likely they're gonna return the
favor
ultimately one of the best modern couch
co-op games in recent years Rayman
legends is exactly what it claims a
legend the platformer gets difficult
especially if you're collecting all the
lumps but working together lightens the
load and if the other player does fall
short they kind of just expand and float
around in the level with you so it makes
the game something you can enjoy with an
experienced player or like your little
niece either way it's challenging and
rewarding with some of the most
tremendous music levels that will leave
you with a massive smile on your face
Diablo 3 easily earns a spot on this
list for being so damn good playing with
a friend will never feel so permanent
because you can spend hundreds of hours
in swirled and still want to play
playing through the campaign is just the
tip of this game the sky is the limit
for your characters progression from
gaining levels and moving on to paragon
levels moving from mastery difficulty to
torment levels 1 through 6 your
character can always be improved like
finding the best weapon ever and then
enhancing it with gems or enchanting it
to change one of the properties and just
wait until you start gambling blood
shards with kadala it's like your
controller is pumping out pure oxygen to
keep you playing you and your friend
will form a permanent bond from this
amazing and seamlessly endless adventure
I think you knew this one was coming
because most people think it's the best
the campaign for left4dead
is perfect for groups because you cannot
do it alone these campaigns are meant
for you to work together and you'll want
your friends fighting by your side so
you can cheer together as you clamor
onto a helicopter or scream at them when
they set off a car alarm this is that
perfect group game when you yell at each
other when you need help or come running
over to revive your fallen friend in
these amazing moments of glory and
failure there's a terrifying group of
special infected that each take unique
tactics to take it down for example the
charger where you might ask when your
friends to play as a decoy while the
others try and take them down from afar
the campaigns are so much fun that even
though you're going down the same path
you'll end up playing them differently
so feels like a new experience each time
you can get a lot of mileage out of
those five different campaigns you can
always go for the gnome run when it
comes to co-op campaigns left4dead
is one of the bests you'll ever play
there's more than enough game play here
to keep you on your couch for probably
the rest of eternity but I'm sure I
missed a few of your favorites so put
them in the comments below and thanks
for watching